emma
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat on va parler ce
matin d outre mer puisque les sénateurs
ont auditionné annick girardin
la ministre en charge des outre-mer
l'occasion de faire le point sur le dé
confinement dans ces territoires
ultramarins sur la relance de l'activité
touristique et sur la crise sanitaire à
mayotte un territoire un placé en zone
rouge où il ya de nombreuses infections
au coït 19 et une sous capacité
hospitalière
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
alors là mme la ministre mes chers
collègues à l'occasion de cette semaine
de déconfinement ou les sorties du
confinement plan national notre
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer a
souhaité vous entendre afin de faire un
point d'étape sur la situation créée par
la crise
je ne sais plus s'il pédiatrie ou de là
il semblerait que sur le plan littéraire
et cognac de l'aco vide les halles un
lien qui avait raison dans le territoire
une pas mal compte tenu des
problématiques spécifiques aux outre-mer
et du risque les mesures annoncées ne
soient pas suffisamment adapté aurait
aux particularités de chacun de nos
territoires
notre délégation a en effet confié à as
trois de ses membres
c'est pas un art and aux ads saint
pierre et miquelon viviane
je prie dieu artigalas socialistes et
républicains hautes-pyrénées et nassimah
dindar union centre et sa réunion le
soin de conduire une étude approfondie
sur l'urgence économique dans les
lourdes depuis deux mois nous avons
ainsi mené une série d'auditions auprès
des acteurs publics et les acteurs puis
il est impliqué dans la relance de nos
territoires
après la phase d'urgence sanitaire qui
semble maîtrisée à ce jour à l'exception
du territoire de mayotte autres la
fédération des entreprises d'outre-mer a
fait l'homme et l'association des
chambres de commerce et d'industrie et
l'outre-mer nous avons entendu
l'agencé française de développement la
banque des territoires caisse des dépôts
la bpi et la présente édition de
s'inscrit dans cette démarche et je vous
remercie madame la minute d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos nombreuses
questions je crois en effet très
important que chacun puisse avoir une
idée très précise des besoins et le
mesures qui ont été déployées dans
chaque territoire
individuellement ainsi que de
l'accompagnement que l'état met en place
qui est indispensable et pour qu'ils
soient le plus pertinent possible compte
tenu de la gravité et de l'ampleur du
tsunami économique nous sommes en train
de vie plus que jamais la démarche de
différenciation que je défends depuis
toujours doit s'appliquer dans les
outre-mer à défaut ils seront privés du
redémarrage auquel la population aspire
et les perspectives de résilience de
notre étude s'attache à prendre une de
nos premières auditions nous revenons à
ce stade deux grands axes de
préoccupation majeure certes les mesures
nationales d'urgence economics implique
en principe aux outre-mer mais les
spécificités de leur tissu économique
induisent un peu trop souvent un effet
d'éviction
voilà une large partie de leur
entreprise la forte proportion des très
petites entreprises et d'entreprise
unipersonnelle la pilosité
traditionnelle du système bancaire le
nom de l'entreprise déjà en grande
difficulté et certaines difficultés
différents statutaire entre les
territoires entre autres tendent à aix
clairement pas en pratique les
encombrants des pans entiers d'activités
du bénéfice des mesures de solidarité
nationale
conscient de
celle qui conscient de cet immense défi
les collectivités concernées se retrouve
dans le même temps privé de levier
d'action habitait en effet les finances
brutale vont subir inéluctablement un
effet de ciseau avec la chute de leurs
recettes fiscales à travers les baisse
inévitable des droits de douane des
taxes sur les carburants des droits de
mutation et pour les drogues du produit
de l'octroi de mer notre collègue john
patient vous a d'ailleurs alerté madame
la ministre à juste titre sur cette
question cruciale
et je crois qu'il a chiffré à 200
millions d'euros sur 2020 les pertes
fiscales pour les collectivités
parallèlement le dépenses d'intervention
pour répondre aux besoins essentiels des
populations vont s'accroître
sans que l'on puisse mesurer encore leur
trajectoire
tous ces éléments nous conduisent à
envisager l'avenir avec une certaine
inquiétude mais également avec une forte
détermination qui est assez
caractéristique d'ailleurs des
populations ultramarines cette
détermination
nous allons donc ans mettre très
rapidement au premier ministre et à
vous-même madame la ministre une
première proposition diagnostic des
propositions sur cette phase actuelle de
déconfinement elle s'articule autour de
deux grandes orientations la nécessité
d'adapter les dispositifs nationaux et
la diversité de gras marine et
l'accompagnement des collectivités dans
leurs politiques de soutien au tissu
économique local
nous vous écouteront attentivement que
ses priorités que nous avons identifiées
au cours des prochaines semaines nous
allons poursuivre notre travail avec des
conditions beaucoup plus thématiques
pour examiner la situation des
différents secteurs d'activité nous
sommes tous des élus de terrain attachés
à nos territoires nous sommes pour la
plupart confiné en raison de la
situation le transport aérien et les
mesures de 14 et ce sujet des transports
aériens fera d'ailleurs l'objet d'une
table ronde que nous organisons la
semaine prochaine et nous sommes tous
agréablement surpris parce que la quasi
totalité des compagnies ont souhaité y
participer ce qui est encourageant
comme vous le savez nous sommes
particulièrement inquiet pour les
secteurs vitaux comme le tourisme qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt le premier
ministre ce matin j'ai pas pu l'écouter
mais je sais qu'il a lancé un plan un
plan pour le tourisme à hauteur de 18
milliards sauf erreur de ma part et
et j'ai même cru comprendre que les
français entre guillemets et y compris
ultra marins pourront aller en vacances
cet été en france et en outre mer ce qui
est une belle ouverture pour les
primaires mais madame denise
comprendrait que le territoire où je
suis et qui vit aussi en grande partie
bien que l'été soit la saison européenne
il vit en grande partie du tourisme à
l'international à quelques inspirations
dont je ne suis pas certain qu'on va
nous ouvrir les frontières tout de suite
mais vous en parlerez peut-être en tout
cas le le premier ministre a dit qu'il
souhaitait établir son plan en
construction avec les professionnels les
secteurs dans le cadre de la cia
tourisme je crois que c'est une bonne
démarche madame la ministre vous nous
direz quelles dispositions spécifiques
ont été décidées pour les premières d'or
ce secteur et qui représente pour lequel
ils ont tiré en l'air d'en moyenne 10%
du pib les territoires pour certains
beaucoup plus je suis placé pour le
savoir et qu'il représente sans doute
l'une des clés l'arbre nous avons donc
beaucoup de questions à vous poser
je vais c'était la parole dans les
dans un premier temps aux trois
rapporteurs pour présenter la question
et avant que vous ne répondiez madame la
ministre et mes chers collègues je vais
faire une petite je vais vous demander
une petite un petit changement par
rapport à l'habitude je souhaite passer
la parole à thani mohamed soilihi
on sait la difficulté dans laquelle se
trouve l'île mayotte et tammy doit nous
laisser ne le voit plus à l'écran par
plus d nord font partie mais il doit
nous laisser je pense d'eux il m'avait
dit 45 minutes après le début s'il
laisse 45 minutes
peut-être que les rapporteurs peut
imposer la question ce qui serait le
plus cohérent en priorité est
indiscutable et annie mettant intro et
10 mois d'utilisation viet tan projet
remercie présidence reviendrait comme ça
si la radio qu'aux exploits je donnerai
la parole aux trois rapporteurs pour la
question al alami nice et à tanis et
madame la ministre vous aurez après le
libre choix de nous répondre puis de
répondre aux questions les autres
intervenants qui s'inscrit donc la
parole pour commencer à je prenne mon
bon papier à des pannes à un panneau
donc sur la sauvegarde du tissu
économique et les mesures d'urgence et
femmes merci président bonjour à toutes
et à tous bonjour madame le ministre
alors j'ai crû comprendre qu une
question d'agenda cet après midi là
simplement pour qu'on sache s'il
l'audition va être écourtées ou si on a
un petit peu de monde
tout le monde a ses micro coupé cette
même liste de répondre mon micro
non j'ai signalé que je veux donner une
priorité aux échanges que nous allons
avoir si je suis pour aller à
l'assemblée j'irai sinon dans le cas
contraire vous resterez avec vous et un
autre ministre défendra l'amendement les
amendements du gouvernement dans le
projet doit de l'assemblée merci
beaucoup alors manger quelques questions
sur la sauvegarde des tissus économiques
dont je vais l'aborder sous 5e volet qui
je pense aux ont déjà été communiqués je
pense le premier c'est le gouvernement
évidemment adopté un certain nombre de
mesures d'urgence au plan national avec
l'activité partielle le fonds de
solidarité et le prêt garanti par l'état
et vous le savez le tissu
entrepreunarial en outre-mer est
essentiellement constituée de tpe avec
des situations de trésorerie extrêmement
fragile
certaines améliorations concernant
notamment le deuxième volet du fond et
des exonérations de charges ont été
annoncés tout récemment mais les acteurs
locaux craignent toujours une vague de
faillites sans précédent en 2020 alors
est ce que le gouvernement écarte
l'éventualité d'un plan spécifique pour
les premières ce sera ma première
question
ensuite quel bilan dressez vous déjà à
ce stade du prêt garanti par l'état donc
le pge en outre mer les conditions de
remboursement pourront-elles être
assouplies au delà de la période
initiale d'un an un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques les entreprises
ultramarines pourront-elles également
bénéficier du fonds de développement
économique et social le fdp es6
dispositions adoptées dans la seconde
loi de finances spécifique hâtif pour
2020 pour les pme est aimé et tpe sites
ont vu refuser notamment
un pg e par leur banque troisième point
comment le dispositif gouvernemental
prend il en compte l'importance de
l'économie informelle dans certains cas
il fera d'autres mères vous le savez je
pense que tannis pourrait le dire mieux
que moi à mayotte elle représente ainsi
les deux tiers des efforts entreprises
marchandes quatrième élément compte tenu
de leur statut
il doit pas être considérée comme un
frein les collectivités du pacifique ne
bénéficie pas du dispositif de
l'activité partielle du chômage partiel
un prêt de l'afd avec une garantie de
l'état a été accordée à la nouvelle
calédonie pour l'aider à financer ses
mesures de chômage partiel
est ce qu'un dispositif similaire est
prévue pour la polynésie française par
exemple si elles ont formulé la demande
bien évidemment et enfin évents
terminerez là en ce qui me concerne à ce
stade le gouvernement ne pourrait-il pas
mobiliser davantage les fonds d'épargné
de la caisse des dépôts et consignations
pour disposer de marges de manoeuvre
financières supplémentaires pour des
projets territoriaux ciblées je vous
remercie
si merci beaucoup chers collègues je
vais pas très la parole donc à viviane
artigalas sur les secteurs clés résumé
rapide
merci monsieur le président bonjour
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
merci à tous d'être ici d'être là moi je
vais donc vous caustique et questionné
sur le soutien aux créateurs qu'elle
pour un redémarrage rapide est le
premier secteur sur lequel je vous aime
les rejoindre et j'insisterai
particulier à un moment c'est sur le
tourisme je suis co pilote de la série
de prises de la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat et j'ai interrogé
jean baptiste lemoyne sur le soutien
spécifique au prisme d'outre-mer il m'a
répondu bien évidemment que toutes les
mesures prévues métropole s'appliquer
aux outre-mer mais ce secteur est encore
plus menacée de deux ans montrent mer et
ce matin le comité interministériel du
tourisme s'est réuni il a eu lieu
quelles mesures concrètes
michel vous l'a déjà demandé se sont
combinés pour le tourisme un autre maire
j'ai bien entendu qu'elle voir philippe
annoncé un seul exemple annoncé que les
vacances des français pourrait avoir
lieu sur tout le territoire
métropolitain et ultramarin
mais par exemple s'il a la question de
la 14ème reste toujours d'actualité dans
les territoires outre-mer
il est bien évident que les séjours
touristiques ne pas avoir lieu
donc c'est une côte et en question une
commission ensuite nous qu'est ce qu'il
ne vous paraît pas nécessaire qu'une
commission dédiée aux spécificités d'une
prise autrement soit constituée et
qu'ils se penchaient plus spécifiquement
sur ce problème
ma deuxième le deuxième secteur
d'activité il est un liant avec le
premier c'est celui de transport aérien
certaines compagnies aériennes risquent
de disparaître alors qu'air france vient
de bénéficier d'un prêt de 5 milliards
d'euros de l'état qu'est le zinc
envisagez vous pour une sortie des
compagnies desservant les outre-mers
indispensable également à la continuité
territoriale
comment comptez-vous intervenir pour
garantir une modération tarifaire il ne
faudrait pas que les tarifs s'envolent
et qui ne permettait plus et aux
résidents et aux touristes de venir un
autre mon troisième point concerne
d'autres secteurs d'activité en effet la
commencer la commande publique risquant
de se raréfier encore après crise
qu'elles l'aident pourront apporter les
institutions financières publiques pour
cpu soutenir les secteurs du btp et du
logement social
quelle est actuellement la volonté du
gouvernement dans ce domaine un
redéploiement de l'armée est le but est
il envisagé sans suite
le secteur des cinq des assurances qui
connaît actuellement une faible
sinistralité ne pourrait pas ne
pourrait-il pas être davantage mis à
contribution pour la reprise et être
incité à prendre en compte le risque
sanitaire dans de futurs contrats et en
plein janvier mon dernier point la crise
a montré l'importance et des messages de
prévention et le maintien des liens
entre ultras marais notamment pour les
jeunes étudiants respect dans l'hexagone
or l'audiovisuel privé à notre mère est
très menacé avec des rosés
cette publicité rangée de 2 81% et la
chaîne france o ù qui doit prochainement
disparaître
ne faudrait-il pas au contraire assurer
l'avenir de ces médias je vous remercie
madame la niche merci beaucoup sur que
tu lègues la parole donc à nassimah de
la cimade art si tu veux bien mettre son
micro nassima et prendre la parole
parfait la ministre assise pour cet
échange bonjour collet alors ma main
mais question relève sur la stratégie
d'avenir pour les outre-mer même si on a
évoqué cette annonce de mesures sur le
tourisme
donc après la crise qui génèrent
d'importantes dépenses et qui entraîne
la perte de recettes et président michel
magras l'a appelé pour les collectivités
ultramarines il l'a rappelé la somme des
200 millions de recettes fiscales entre
2019 et 2020 ce sont les estimations de
paix pour les collectivités
territoriales en sachant que celle ci
réalisent 70% des investissements
publics
comment pourrait-elle poursuivre cet
effort à l'arrière dans différents
différents domaines on a parlé également
donc du btp est-ce que vous soutenez
madame la mise la proposition de la
porte des territoires de réactiver pour
les outre-mer le dispositif de
préfinancement de la fctva qui a été
déjà mis en place en 2008 c'était ma
première question
la deuxième question relève de la
souveraineté alimentaire mais je
voudrais faire un petit point également
sur la la la l'autonomie salutaire mais
sur la souveraineté alimentaire
quelles aides pourraient être destinés
aux producteurs locaux qui ont souvent
réussi à apporter des réponses
innovantes pour aider les populations
face à la crise et comment pensez-vous
soutenir ces évolutions en cours
est ce que le gouvernement prévoit des
mesures concrètes pour renforcer
l'autonomie alimentaire des territoires
à travers un soutien spécifique au
secteur agriculture et aussi au secteur
de la pêche
ma troisième question concerne
l'amélioration des réseaux d'eau dans
certaines collectivités qui en ont
vraiment besoin je pense à la guadeloupe
mais également à mayotte et notre
collègue sénateur thani ne va pas
démenti est ce que je dis est ce qu'on
envisage pour renforcer également donc
ces réseaux d'eau de des projets
structurants qui pourraient accompagner
par par étapes et également pour
renforcer l'autonomie sanitaires les
équipements le matériel sanitaire et
est-ce qu'on pourrait assouplir
également pour mayotte la règle et
médecin parce que nous savons qu'il en
manque
est-ce qu'il faut obligatoirement avoir
des médecins qui viennent ou de
l'hexagone n'est ce qu'on ne peut pas
envisager qu'on en fasse venir de la
zone océan indien
donc c'est emma la troisième session
puis en simple sur le budget européen
qui qui a été votée pour 2021 jusqu'à
quels financements l'union européenne
pourrait mobiliser pour soutenir la
stratégie de développement post crise
des territoires ultramarins on entend
des chiffres mais nous ne savons pas
encore comment ce travail se fait en
coordination avec les aides nationales
et puis bien évidemment nous avons
entendu les représentants de l'afd ils
voudraient ils sont ils sont favorables
à ce que on puisse couple et les fonds
les fonds feder et des aides européennes
qui sont apportées pour la coopération
régionale
on pense à l'océan indien mais aussi à
la zone pacifique et à la zone pareil
voilà pour les questions donc qui
complète celle de mes collègues en
remerciant la ministre et monsieur le
président chapeau l'est merci cher que
l'ale donc la parole à tanis est appelé
à la ministre un père année mieux volant
vous n'êtes merci mais ce président cher
michel merci aux collègues d'accepter
cette petite entorse
un bonjour madame la ministre j'ai deux
questions la première suite au
classement de mayotte en rouge pour
parler simplement de déconfinement n'est
pas encore d'actualité pour nous et ça
se comprend parfaitement
je voulais vous demander quels sont un
peu les perspectives en vue du de
confinement l'économie doit reprendre
ses droits comme partout où j'allais
dire encore plus dans ce territoire où
l'économie est très très fragile
les commerces doivent voir mourir dont
elles sont les perspectives
en disant ça je sais que la situation
est très compliquée sur fond de pillages
sur fond de délinquance qui qui galope
les délinquants ne se sentent pas à
conditionner le et en profite pour
perturber perturbé lille
et justement c'est l'objet de ma
deuxième question il ya eu une polémique
récemment à l'occasion d'une cuillère
laquelle vous avez pondu à l'assemblée
nationale où vous avez vous êtes revenu
sur cette délinquance si vous avez dit
un chiffre qui tendrait la baisse de
cette délinquance alors les réactions se
sont focalisés sur cbs que vous avez
annoncé et beaucoup de réactions par lh2
de mépris de manque de considération de
votre part ce qui n'est pas du tout ce
qui ne correspond pas du tout à la
réalité je me dois de l'objectif était
de dire lorsque l'on a vu ces derniers
mois ces dernières années comment vous
est venu au chevet de de ce département
en particulier
est-ce que vous pouvez être plus précise
sur cette cette question sur la
délinquance sur laquelle vous avez été
interrogé par le député go cela et vous
expliquer davantage
est ce que ces chiffres tiennent compte
du fait que par exemple une bonne partie
de la population qui est finalement en
fait que les leurs plaies ne sont pas
prises en considération
venant des poses plus est ce qu'on
pouvait revenir là dessus
voilà mes mais deux questions en
remercie encore une fois cher collègue
michel merci monsieur lui dans mercy
chatani madame la ministre début c'est
tout un panel de questions
donc vous avez la parole et je vais vous
mettre en gros plan sur mon écran doit
vous aiguille ils avaient la parole eh
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
président merci à tous et dames les
sénatrices et sénateurs de cet échange
qu'on a je crois que c'est toujours
important de les avoir régulièrement il
ya tout juste un mois je faisais un
point avec l'assemblée nationale et la
délégation de l'assemblée nationale
était important de faire avec vous
presque un mois après d'autant qu' on
est dans un monde où une vérité après 48
heures de ville et tout s'adapte deux
jours en douze jours voire les données
que l'on enfermé et l'adaptation dont on
est capable à tous les niveaux oblige à
ce genre de des changes régulier pour
qu' on puisse montrer ou de montrer les
évolutions et les mesures qui sont
prises
alors pour répondre aux sénateurs artero
sur la sauvegarde du tissu économique et
les mesures les mesures d'urgence
rappeler très rapidement que un arsenal
massif de mesures qu'on soutenir notre
économie a été mis en place de chômage
partiel bien sûr dont bénéficient
d'ailleurs plus de 60% des salariés du
secteur privé dans les droits et les 3,5
des prêts garantis c'est effectivement
par l'état également soutenir la
trésorerie des entreprises
et là c'est presque un milliard d'euros
aujourd'hui mobilisée regarde les
chiffres et à mesure des demandes de
chacun et puis le report de charges
fiscales et sociales
et là je fais aussi là
des choses entre les drom les les 3 1 et
les collectivités du pacifique bien sûr
ces mesures ne s'appliquent pas toutes
de la même manière selon les territoires
et leurs compétences
et puis il ya le fonds de solidarité
pour les très petites entreprises et les
travailleurs indépendants avec le
deuxième volet vous en avez parler
monsieur le sénateur de ce fort qui est
piloté par les régions et les critères
ont été déterminées avec les
associations ou l'association des
régions de france et c'est important de
dire parce que ça a été construit avec
régions de france et je sais que
certains vétérans monte effectivement
lors leur demande
mais l'état a demandé que ce fonds qui
est piloté par les régions et les
critères qui ont été déterminés par les
associations des régions de france
puisse éventuellement évoluer pour
campus dans ce dispositif fait rentrer
le maximum d'entreprises
donc moi aussi j'ai une recommandation à
faire puisque l'état a posé le cadre la
négocier avec les régions si nous avons
des régions dans le territoire à marine
et fanara qui souhaite effectivement
faire évoluer ce dispositif pour tenir
compte des spécificités des territoires
avec moi je les invite à se rapprocher
effectivement des préfet et à regarder
comment en cours adaptés toutes ces
mesures j'avais déjà indiqué à tous les
préfets de tous les territoires amara
qu'il fallait de l'adaptation de la
souplesse et davantage d'accompagnement
dans les territoires ultramarins
pour pouvoir bénéficier de toutes ces
aides selon les territoires c'est ce qui
a été mis en place a été mis en place
aussi des cellules d'urgence économique
j'avais demandé et ses cellules
d'urgence économique elle fonctionne
plus ou moins bien selon le territoire
parce que tous chacun s'y investit aussi
investi par et ça c'est vraiment
j'aurais envie de dire des dynamiques
locales qui ont su mettre ou pas et puis
est ce qu'il ya un plan spécifique
outre-mer un choix qu'il faut être là
dessus très pragmatique il faut d'abord
s'assurer que les mesures nationales
soient pleinement applicable dans tous
les territoires hamas pour ça que je
vais effectivement à l'ensemble de ces
mesures et comment elles se déclinent
dans les territoires et on a fait en
sorte d'ailleurs que certaines qui
n'avaient pas automatiquement vocation à
être mise en place en nouvelle calédonie
où
en polynésie française chrysler je pense
par exemple à la bpi qui est pas
toujours présente et pour lequel on
n'avait pas branché les tuyaux pour ce
type de texte est aujourd'hui fait et je
veux ici remarque me remerciez à la
caisse des dépôts et la bpi sur leurs
engagements sur le b sur le le pge c'est
quoi le pg est un dispostif massif de
garantie des prêts en trésorerie aux
entreprises je n'en parle et qui peuvent
représenter jusqu'à trois mois de
chiffre d'affaires et la bpi a déployé
pour 300 milliards de garanties de
plaisir garanti s'est très vite mise en
place au maire et on peut s'en féliciter
y compris d'ailleurs dans les
collectivités vient de dire du pacifique
et ça c'était une bonne nouvelle pour
nos amis du pacifique depuis
toutefois les entreprises l'ont bien
compris la période d'annoncés peur n'est
pas la période limitée de remboursement
mais bien le délit qui est donnée pour
commencer le remboursement celui ci il
s'étale sur cinq années selon les
négociations qui ont pu avoir lieu vous
avez évoqué aussi monsieur le sénateur
le fdf baisse et qui a été effectivement
augmenté son emploi pas été augmentée à
750 millions c'est aujourd'hui un
milliard d'euros qui sont applicables
dans les territoires amar a mené dans
les territoires sont des drogues
essentiellement partante et en revanche
sur ai envie de dire eh bien les
entreprises se ferait refuser un des
jeux eux par leur banque et bien bercy
travaille sur un dispositif spécifique
de près et d'avant-bourse à côté
aujourd'hui de 500 millions d'euros j'ai
demandé à ce que ces dispositifs soient
étendus aux collectivités d'être amer à
toutes les collectivités d'outre-mer aux
pommes et d'allemand à l'instar des
autres dispositifs que nous avons mis en
place
pg e ou f est ce bien entendu quand il
faut être bien clair le fds et le
système d'avancés remboursables sont
deux choses différentes mais qui
viennent compléter effectivement
certains territoires ou pour d'autres
les mesures d'accompagnement qui ont été
mis en place jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
sur l'objectif de sortir de l'informel
d'inciter à sortir de la fournaise c'est
une vraie
c'est une vraie question on y travaille
déjà depuis un moment et notamment avec
l'adie puisque depuis le 1er juin 2019
avec frédéric lavenir président de
l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique l'a dit on à l
outre-mer a mis effectivement 1,8
million d'euros pour permettre à tous
les territoires avec des mentions
particulières sur mayotte sur la guyane
sur sa matin et soir la poésie française
pour faire en sorte qu'en latine parce
que ce sont souvent des très petites et
très petites structures en attire ce qui
fonctionne dans l'informel vers quelque
chose qu'on structure petit à petit avec
eux on a bien vu d'ailleurs que la fin
de l'activité informelle dans les
territoires pouvez même aller jusqu'à
provoquer certaines violences dans
certains territoires où la faim qui a
touché mayotte la guyane notamment en
possession de territoires mais les
d'autres ont été aussi touché dans cet
objectif nous y travaillons et nous
apportant des réponses également son
forme de insultes et à la formation pour
effectivement rentré dans le dans le
formel je le fais aussi bien sûr avec ma
collègue pénicaud sur ce sur ce dossier
enfin vous avez évoqué les prêts à aider
aux deux territoires du pacifique la
nouvelle calédonie a demandé l'aide de
l'état ayant subi effectivement une
crise forte également ses 240 millions
de prêts garantis et rap qui ont été
accordés à la nouvelle calédonie la
polynésie a déjà fait sa demande de
soutien également alors les deux
territoires ne se compare pas le pays
les deux territoires ont subi la crise
mais la trésorerie de certaines étaient
nettement plus favorable que l'autre est
donc aujourd'hui la sève et est en train
de traiter la demande de la polynésie et
que nous allons pouvoir avancer la plus
grosse des difficultés notamment pour la
polynésie c'est la caisse de prévoyance
sociale qui est confronté à un risque de
rupture de trésorerie à brève échéance
et n'oublions pas ces deux collectivités
du du passé fier que préside la
république a eu l'occasion de leurs
deux présidents de ces territoires il ya
maintenant une semaine sur la question
de alors sur la question du tourisme
maintenant notamment sur le conseil
interministériel vieux tourisme
plusieurs annonces ont été faites ce
matin par le premier ministre qui bien
entendu a fait en sorte que toutes ces
aides puissent aussi venir aider les
autres amara et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure
le premier ministre a rappelé que cet
été très certainement les français
seront appelés à redécouvrir la france
parce que les voyages l'international
vont être compliqués que sur la partie
européenne on n'a pas aujourd'hui
véritablement de réponse est donc on va
insulter au voyage en france et en
france il a précisé que c'était bien sûr
l'hexagone mais que c'était aussi
l'outre-mer et c'est important qu'on
puisse le dire parce que beaucoup et
notamment le tourisme affinitaire
d'abord fait qu'aujourd'hui il y à de
fortes demandes et l'avis du conseil
scientifique qui a été publié hier soir
par le ministère des outre-mer vous avez
tous ces témoins tous les parlementaires
notre mère ont été destinataires de cet
avis du conseil scientifique
il rappelle effectivement les conditions
pour venir dans le territoire dont 3 mai
rappelle l'objectif de la 14ème qu'elle
soit aujourd'hui en structure collective
et qu'elle soit à domicile et on pourra
revenir sur ces conditions et sur l'avis
du conseil constitutionnel si vous le si
vous le voulez mais le ce ce comité
scientifique ouvre aussi avec une
troisième proposition qui permettrait
peut-être davantage de réouvrir au
tourisme affinitaire
et puis bien sûr je continuerai à
demander des avis de cette commission
même si sept ans de ce conseil
scientifique même si et on en est tous
d'accord ici c'est bien aux politiques
de faire des choix au final et puis ces
choix un premier ministre vient rappeler
ils se feront avec les les élus des
différents territoires c'est un travail
qui sera mené avec le ministre le moigne
sur le volet touristique il a été
convenu effectivement on a plus
les mesures mais qu'on puisse présenter
reprenant les mesures nationales
ce dispositif aux ultramarins et donc ce
ne sera pas un tendre spécifique là non
plus mais bien comment on adapte dans
les territoires d'outre-mer les
différentes mesures je voulais rappelle
fréquemment le police a lancé le fonds
de solidarité que le fonds de solidarité
resteraient ouverts pour les entreprises
du secteur du chr et tourisme jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2020 vous étiez nombreux
à l'avoir demandé les forêts des
parlementaires sont très nombreux et
l'as vence de pas pouvoir répondre aussi
vite que vous ne voudriez à tous parce
que on est dans l'action parce que on
est énormément pris sur d'autres
chantiers à nouveau chantier chaque jour
mais j'essaye d'être au grand rendez
vous et c'est l'occasion d'ailleurs de
vous donner les réponses en direct
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2020 ce fonds
de solidarité qui élargit aux
entreprises de plus grande taille parce
qu'on avait fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est à dire entreprises de plus de 20
salariés ça concerne souvent à thomas
l'autre en mer bien peu et juste à 10
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
l'aide à laquelle il faudra pour a donné
droit effectivement a augmenté aussi il
savait le plafond à 10000 euros pour le
monde du tourisme sur le deuxième étage
du fonds de solidarité qui aujourd'hui a
été donné un sacré coup au moral et à
dix mille tours
les entreprises du tourisme et de
l'événementiel pourront continuer à
recourir à l'activité partielle dans les
mêmes conditions jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 ensuite négociations se
fera il aura une poursuite de ceux de ce
chômage partiel et temps pour échanger
un plan d'investissement et là c'est
important aussi pour nous dans les
territoires et leurs camarades parce que
je pense qu'on peut aussi profiter de
ces mois d'attentes dans certains cas
pour monter de niveau notre offre est
bien un plan d'investissement en fonds
trottent de 1,1 milliard d'euros qui
sont rapportés par la caisse des dépôts
et par la bpi france pour un effet
attendues en matière d'investissement de
6,7 milliards d'euros une exonération de
cotisations sociales qui va s'appliquer
aux tpe et aux pme pendant la période de
fermeture ou
de très faible activité au mois de mars
de mars à juin pour un montant estimé à
2,2 milliards d'euros
les collectivités locales sont aussi
invités à alléger la taxe de séjour ou
d'hébergement touristique
elles pourront également ce qu'il fait
de réduire de deux tiers les cotisation
foncière des entreprises du tourisme et
l'état viendra accompagner la
collectivité elle viendra exactement
financer la moitié de ces efforts qui
seraient faits par les collectivités
sous réserve de l'évolution de
l'épidémie et de possibles restrictions
localiser vous savez il y a aujourd'hui
en france des territoires qui sont en
zone rouge et des territoires qui sont
en zone verte pour les territoires
outre-mer
il n'ya que mayotte aujourd'hui qui est
dans ce donc dans cette partie des
colorés en rouge et bien le gouvernement
soit effectivement que les vacances de
juillet août puisse puisse se faire et a
mis en place un système de remboursement
intégral avec les professions de
l'hôtellerie et du tourisme
toute réservation qui se fait à partir
d'aujourd'hui le cas où les landes vais
revenir en arrière parce que l'épidémie
évolue ray hé bien les remboursements
serait fait tout ça effectivement un
temps d'assister aux déplacements c'est
un plan global de 18 milliards d'euros
et je vous ai dit qu'il sera décliné
dans les territoires ultramarins et ses
décisions qui ont été prises me font
dire effectivement à monsieur anoh que
le fonds d'épargné de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations va donc être
mobilisés bien entendu pour faire ses
traits qui n'ont jamais été dans le
temps aussi blanc en remboursement et
les conditions seront présentées par
chaque chaque organisme pour répondre
aux questions de la sénatrice viviane
artigalas je viens de lire effectivement
dans un premier temps cette fiche je
vais reprendre les autres questions que
vous m'avez posé et notamment sur la ria
c'est ce que j'ai expliqué ce matin à
cette réunion touristique c'est que
les territoires ultramarins pour
connaître à tourisme cet été ça veut
dire que nous reprenons un certain
nombre de vols parce que si on métropole
on peut le faire en train ou en voiture
une fois l'avion et donc on a bien un
lien entre cette activité du
développement touristique
et puis la réouverture des territoires
pour permettre effectivement ce tourisme
affinitaire d'autres types de tourisme
si on le souhaitait nous devons
travailler ensemble et réaliser ce
chantier ensemble et les compagnies
aériennes sont directement effectivement
concernés alors moi je voudrais ici
rappeler que les compagnies aériennes
qui desservent nos territoires sont
essentielles à la continuité
territoriale j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire à une question qui m'a été posée
par un parlementaire
et de rappeler que et de remercier les
compagnies qui ont continué à travailler
pendant cette période de crise et
souvent à perte
bien sûr il ya la compagnie air france
et la compagnie air austral et puis
l'état à organiser des dépens aérien
entre la réunion et mayotte entre la
polynésie et et et paris et il faut
effectivement aujourd'hui que nous
puissions continuer à soutenir ses
compagnes et de manière à ce que l
puisse continuer à rendre les services
importants en matière d'habitat y monde
et sur les territoires
je pense effectivement à tout ce qui y
est sanitaire mais aussi au quotidien de
ce que nous répondre aux besoins du
quotidien
alors bien entendu ce que l'on fait
actuellement c'est de voir avec chaque
compagnie aérienne dans chaque bassin
maritime france à epagny cette nuit je
pense victime hors cac air canada air
austral je pense à air caraïbes je pense
à saint-pierre enfin nous avons de
nombreuses compagnies qui dessert les
territoires drama et qui souvent
d'ailleurs 100 ans dans leur compte dans
leurs actionnaires des collectivités
territoriales pour air austral est et la
région réunion pour air câlin et pour un
pour tahiti nui c'est bien sûr les deux
gouvernements donc on a un travail à
faire aussi avec les collectivités qui
sont actionnaires qui ont leur part de
responsabilité comme tous les autres
actionnaires d'ailleurs donc un on
vérifie qu'ils ont bien utilisé tous les
dispositifs corps et emi
à leur place en place par l'état c'est
ce que j'ai demandé effectivement à
chacun et au préfet dit veiller et de me
remonter les conditions je suis à des
des territoires ensuite c'est de dire il
faut absolument qu'on ait un travail et
bruno le maire l'a rappelé avec les
actionnaires pour pouvoir les
accompagner davantage dans le temps
et puis ce qui est demandé par toutes
ces compagnies c'est de savoir comment
et à quelles conditions ils pourront
réouvrir vous savez le premier ministre
a donné la date du 2 juin pour une
première vague de réouverture sans doute
de restaurant ou d'activités dites
touristiques ou de loisirs et puis sans
doute une autre vague avant la fin du
mois de juin
tu seras sera déterminé au tour du 28
mai et c'est à ce moment là d'ailleurs
que pour les territoires d'outre-mer
nous pouvons aussi faire un certain
nombre d'alliances
alors en ce qui concerne effectivement
la commande publique
c'est un sujet important et moi vous
savez je n'ai pas attendu effectivement
cette crise on parle fortement du btp et
des infrastructures à construire sur les
territoires ultramarins je viens de
faire une chronique des paiements dus à
fully pour remonter sur l'année 2018 et
2019 pourquoi parce qu'à ce moment là
ont versé trop sens au collectif crédit
à du montant du projet bien ses 30 ans
en 2018 et en 2019 cette année en 2020
on malaxe sp pour cent j'ai souhaité
quand remonte sur 2018 et 2019 et qu'on
verse aux collectivités le complément
entre le 30 et le 50 % en clair je viens
de redonner aux collectivités 11
millions d'euros de trésorerie à pour
ces collectivités pour des chantiers
2018 certainement commencer et je
l'espère bien
et pour les chantiers 2019 2020
on est bien dans le contexte du 50%
versée dès la signature avec l'état des
projets à fully je voudrais vous dire
ici que la presque totalité des crédits
du fmi 2020 ont été effectivement a
lancé à chaque collectivité les
engagements ont été pris s'est engagé
aujourd'hui ou dans les heures qui
viennent
pour qu'effectivement on soit à la
hauteur des besoins
cette importance un facteur économique
majeur dans nos télés parafenuik jeu
pour le haut conseil de la commande
publique de réunir et cette semaine
devant de demain c'est demain vendredi
voilà c'est de voir les léo conseils
pour créer une dynamique avec eux des
réunions régulier avec de lire pour voir
comment on utilise l'ensemble de ce
crédit est fautive est aussi bien sur
les contrats de 30 de transformer en
formation de développement et de
transformation selon les territoires la
question était sur la lb où j'ai demandé
à chaque préfet de me faire un poids
élevé eu engagements à la date nous
parlons de manière avait attribué s'il
faut je voudrais vous dire que la cdc
habitat projette de racheter des
immeubles en construction à des
promoteurs dans les territoires amara
s'est taillé nuit-là 6000 logements
c'est autant de chantiers qui vont être
lancés en 2020 et 2021 et ça représente
entre 100 et 120 millions d'euros pour
2020 et 2021 sur la question des
assurances bien on va se dire la vérité
les assurances il a fallu aller les
chercher pour qu'elles soient à nos
côtés en même temps je voudrais dire que
elle se sent aussi des entreprises qui
subissent la crise on est allé les
chercher et ils sont au rendez vous
d'abord effectivement c'est une
manoeuvre de 200 millions d'euros au
fonds de solidarité et puis on a
retravaillé ensemble et se font il a été
porté à 400 millions d'euros
il participe également au plan de
relance touristique que vous verrez le
détail dans ce plan quand il sera publié
moi je vais avec jean-baptiste lemoyne
travailler effectivement est avec vous
tous sur le plan et la relance trop
festif dans les territoires on part à la
dernière question étaient les deux
dernières prennent la dernière question
madame la sénatrice était sur les médias
outre mer alors décrit dans notre merde
depuis que je suis arrivé que tu là
depuis trois ans il y en a eu beaucoup
il y en a eu beaucoup et la plus grosse
difficulté dans cette crise a bien été
les fêtes nous et on voit bien qu'il
nous faut des médias forts des médias
informe et qui effectivement viennent
dans les territoires amar a présenté les
projets en a besoin d'eux et y compris
d'ailleurs dans la prépension les
messages à passer
il faut qu'on soutienne nos médias mais
ils ont subi de grosses pertes dans
leurs recettes notamment dans le début
de cette crise ça revient parce qu'on a
relancé effectivement la publicité sur
ses chaînes sur ces journaux il faut
qu'on puisse continuer à le faire et
avec le ministère de la culture et nous
avions commencé avant la crise parce que
il y avait des sujets médias a présenté
un mécanisme de soutien
j'espère que nous serons en mesure dans
les semaines qui viennent de l'annoncer
publiquement
madame la sénatrice nassimah dindar vous
m'avez interrogé sur les finances
locales on a eu l'occasion d'en parler
beaucoup avec le président de la
république qu'il a il ya maintenant dix
jours dialoguer avec tous les présidents
de départements de région et les
présidents des associations de maires de
dire que plusieurs mesures avaient été
effectivement prises d'abord le premier
ministre a donné une mission au député
cazenave que vous connaissez qui avait
déjà fait un travail avec le député
patients sur les dotations aux
collectivités territoriales et je
voudrais rappeler que ce rapport passion
15 9 il est loin d'être abouti il y
avait de fortes recommandations
effectivement il est un peu de côté le
temps de la crise d urgence mais toutes
les recommandations sont à reprendre
et puis le député canal va faire des
demandes fin des propositions
supplémentaires il faut qu'ils puissent
objectiver les différentes demandes
territoire par territoire collectivités
par collectivité de manière à ce que
nous pouvons nous puissions venir les
soutenir très attentive au travail à
ceux à ce travail on a aussi fait en
sorte que lier des versements anticipés
c'est signé récemment une instruction
qui rappelle notamment la possibilité de
faire des annonces
sur le 12e de fiscalité alors là ça
concerne les drom bien sûr et puis je
souhaite effectivement dire que ya la
difficulté des communes la marine
qu'elles ont quand même des recettes
presque garanti jusqu'en décembre
puisque les régions effectivement
alimente aujourd'hui les communes c'est
plus après qu'il va falloir aussi
intervenir les régions elles qui
supportent se voit y compris de soutien
aux collections aux communes alors que
l'octroi de mer et toucher à leur pack
taxe sur les carburants et touche et
nous avons alors que l'économie des
territoires en berne fait qu'il ya moins
de il ya moins de recettes donc avec
chaque collectivité
nous travaillerons à apporter des
réponses pour qu'on ait un retour aux
équilibres vous savez tout ce qu elle
dans quelles conditions effectivement
sont certaines collectivités etc enfin
certaines difficultés budgétaires et je
pense et je n'oublie pas qu'elle ya la
difficulté des délais de paiement qui
sont énormes donc soutenir les
collectivités c'est aussi soutenir les
entreprises qui attendent d'être payés
sur un certain nombre de territoires
pour ne pas dire dans la presque
totalité des territoires
la question de l'autonomie alimentaire
madame la sénatrice est aussi essentiel
est là vraiment on est au coeur mais
mais mais déjà depuis un certain nombre
de temps vous savez la visite du
président de la république à la réunion
a été l'occasion de parler de cette
autonomie alimentaire
c'est pour ça que près de la république
à ce que tu es un délégué
interministériel à la transformation
agricole est là pour accélérer justement
les travaux et sa première mission était
à la réunion avant effectivement de se
rendre dans l'est dans les antilles pour
adapter on pour accompagner cette
transformation je pense aussi aux
circuits pour qu'il nous faut valoriser
davantage et à cette occasion je
voudrais dire que je voudrais remercier
de l'innovation dans les territoires
ultramarins
quand on a effectivement prévu que des
premiers donc que certains avaient su
utiliser l'europe pour faire du gel
hydro hydroalcoolique
on voit bien que l'innovation est au
coeur aussi des réponses de demain et on
est bien dans le circuit court et vous
qu'on puisse continuer bien entendu les
annonces financières qui avaient eu lieu
à ce moment là
a tenu sans doute et on verra un
travaillant déjà tout ce qui a été mis
en capacité financière sur les
territoires elle ira à une augmentation
de ses de ses moyens et pour finir
rapidement deux sujets là réseau de
l'eau les réseaux d'eau c'est une
question extrêmement brûlante dans les
territoires d'outre-mer c'est une
problématique qui est rappelé
régulièrement dans les territoires
ultramarins et obligatoirement de crise
les choses vont encore plus mal et donc
on les voit encore plus et donc cette
question de l'eau elle est essentielle
elle est différente selon les les
territoires je pense effectivement à la
guadeloupe à la martinique qui en des
problèmes d'infrastructures certains de
gouvernance de vieillissement des dés de
leur structure il faut qu'on sorte de
cette espèce de spirale qui fait qu' on
est dans dégradation des services rendus
aux usagers fuite panne donc perte de
confiance et donc impayés et donc pas
d'argent pour investir il faut
effectivement qu en sorte de tout ça je
voudrais aussi rappeler que il ya ces
problématiques antillaise on va dire
qu'on peut retrouver dans d'autres tiers
territoire mais aussi mayotte la guyane
où la déficit en infrastructures étaient
effectivement présents il faut que nous
puissions revenir voir là aussi à des
travaux plus importants d'autant qu'il
ya une augmentation de la démographie
dans ces deux territoires qui doivent
être présents qui doivent être pris en
compte alors quelques chiffres le plan
d'actions prioritaires en guadeloupe ses
71 millions et le préfet de la
guadeloupe a fait quelques réquisitions
dernièrement vous permettent
effectivement d'avancer vers des
solutions d'urgence mais aussi de faire
en sorte que cette gouvernance soit
modifié en guadeloupe et qu'on puisse
enfin être au niveau de ce qui est
attendu
parce que c'est totalement inadmissible
par nos concitoyens sur mayotte ses 67
millions d'euros pour l'eau potable et
l'assainissement dans le fbi que je
viens de signer une grande partie vent
sur des projets eau et assainissement
il ya 70 millions également de l'office
française de la biodiversité qui ont été
mobilisés avec
la éviter tous les territoires et puis
bien entendu nous allons très vite
réorganiser des cycles pour travailler
sur ses plans au pour que en soit à la
hauteur des attentes mais encore une
fois je parle bien là à vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et vous savez
tous parce que vous êtes aussi beaucoup
d élus locaux
vous savez tous que la problématique de
l'eau c'est pas les pères qui va la
règle et salle parce que c'est une
compétence avant tout locale que l'état
soir aux côtés des collectivités c'est
normal que les têtes quelquefois soient
obligés d'aller jusqu'à la réquisition
si les choses se passent mal
pourquoi pas mais entre les deux
franchement et honnêtement il faudra
qu'on se mobilise davantage tous
ensemble sinon on n'y arrivera pas etc
le dernier message que je voulais
effectivement vous délivrer de manière à
ce que ce soit tous ensemble qu'on
puisse de fer et en emmenant les
différentes collectivités concernées les
mairies les opci à avancer sur ces
sujets et a dépassé peut-être quelques
fois les clivages politiques même dans
cette période politique ou de campagne
électorale qui continue c'est pas
toujours toujours facile sur la dernière
question des médecins étrangers à
mayotte
c'est une mesure réglementaire qui est
mis en place pour la guyane et pour les
antilles mais si nous en avons besoin à
mayotte
eh bien nous pouvons effectivement
adapter rapidement le texte et le
permettent pour privilégier
effectivement la possibilité d'avoir un
renfort dans la région
s'il est nécessaire non pas pour
l'instant est en période de crise c'est
d'abord des renforts nationaux qui sont
envoyées dans tous les territoires sur
le volet hospitalisation enfin niveau de
niveau sanitaire et conditions de prise
en compte des soins dans les territoires
ultramarins
il ya le temps de la crise la police de
comines 19 je vais pas vous rappeler
tous les engagements qui ont été pris et
à la fois les envois de masques de
capacités test de doublement des lits
de deux réacteurs et animations etc
faudrait simplement vous rappeler qu' il
ya des projets finalisés
l'état s'est engagé fortement le chu de
fort de france avec 969 milliards
d'euros la construction du pôle
sanitaire de l'ouest la réunion 131
millions d'euros la reconstruction à
saint laurent du maroni pour 147
millions d'euros et puis sont en cours
et vous le savez la construction du chu
de pointe à pitre
c'est parce que 590 millions d'euros'
avait été annoncé il ya maintenant de
nombreuses pas plus le plus d'une année
que ces mêmes quatre ans que ce projet a
été annoncé l'hôpital est bien sorti de
terre j'ai l'occasion de faire trois cas
de visite sur cette structure avec le
président de région et président de
département dans cet enfer avance le
plus vite possible ils savaient focal de
diane audet ouaddou pardon a aussi subi
un incendie il ya effectivement
l'hôpital de mamoudzou à mayotte qui a
nécessité un investissement de 27
millions d'euros mais ya celui de
mamoudzou à mayotte qui va a fait un
investissement de 172 millions d'euros
et puis l'offre hospitalière ou
martinique regroupement de l'offre
hospitalière pour lequel l'état a engagé
à 38,7 38 27 millions d'euros sur laura
et les différentes les différents
partenariats au projet que nous avons en
la matière d'abord je dois dire que je
travaille en concertation régulière avec
le député européen stéphane stéphane
bijoux que c'est position comme les
nôtres c'est bien de défendre les
intérêts des rup et des p t om se porter
aussi bien sûr par l'ensemble du groupe
renaissance à bruxelles
il ya aussi des avancées bien sûr
pendant laquelle de la crise les deux
initiatives d'investissement
en réaction à des russes qui ont été
prises par la commission mais aussi
l'adaptation avec les modifications du
fait en fait là je réponds à une
question pêche ou encore le plan de
relance économique auquel participera
europe
vous savez c'est avec les rup avec
l'épée thorel que nous travaillons sur
le prochain budget européen
l'europe doit être au rendez vous et
nous continuons à travailler ensemble et
je vois régulièrement les différents
élus on la matière on avait parlé un peu
de coopération régionale permettez moi
de conclure sur ce sujet avant de
parfaits au tourisme et de répondre à
tanis madame la sénatrice cher sma sur
la coopération régionale
on en parle beaucoup elle se concrétise
souvent assez peu et on voit en ce
moment de crise que chaque territoire
c'est complètement refermé sur lui même
et que la coopération régionale on l'a
quand même largement oubliée dans ce
moment et qu'elle est là clairement
porté suffisamment sur le sujet
sanitaires et donc il va falloir que
nous puissions relancer ces sujets et
rapidement je vais demander ou trois
ambassadeurs des différentes zones qui
sont issus au ministère d outre-mer la
france va présider la coi en 2021 et
donc j'ai proposé la candidature de
monsieur marim marimoutou que je le
prononce bien il va prendre ses
fonctions le 1er juillet etc les deux
missions qui lui sont donnés que je
souhaite effectivement rappelé avec mon
collègue du ministère des affaires
étrangères c'est bien le sujet éducatif
et le sujet sanitaires pour répondre
effectivement à la question de de
mayotte
je sais que ma réponse à l'assemblée
nationale a choqué au compte du moins
c'est ce que j'ai pu lire effectivement
sur les réseaux sociaux
et je sais que les chiffres que j'ai
données peuvent paraître éloigné du
ressenti au quotidien des mahorais c'est
toujours la grande difficulté entre
effectivement donné des chiffres
généraux dans un pays dans un territoire
et puis à côté que ce chiffre ils
viennent percuter et c'est normal le
ressenti ou le vécu de quelqu'un dans
son quartier dans sa maison dans son
village où furent un événement
particulier et donc j'ai l'habitude
d'être toujours très transparente et
très direct rares sont ceux qui sont
allés aussi souvent moins en tant que
ministre dans les territoires
ultramarins vincent ceux qui ont été
aussi au quotidien faire la main en
permanence aux côtés de mayotte que moi
depuis le début de mois mon arrivée ici
si j'ai choqué les maoris c'est que nous
ne sommes pas contre oui oui c'est les
chiffres globalement effectivement la
violence a baissé et vous le savez et
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur
famille avec qui nous travaillons
toujours très bien comme avec la députée
nattier ali ces chiffres viennent de la
baisse de plaintes déposées
alors on peut s'interroger en vérité est
ce que les gens vont moins porté plainte
parce qu'ils estiment que ça change pas
grand chose ou est ce que la période
confinement a fait que game one et oui
nous avons des jeunes sur ce territoire
qui malheureusement sont bien trop
souvent violent mais les cette violence
elle est souvent elles expriment souvent
la détresse
elle exprime souvent un désespoir
l'ennui bien évidemment n'est rien
excuses
ces violences et vous le savez nous
sommes sur le territoire avec l'ensemble
des forces qui ont été mobilisés et nous
veillons avec le ministre qu'un salaire
à ce que l'effort soit près de dix ans
présentent soit tous mobilisés et nous
n'avons jamais hésité en période de
crise où quand c'est nécessaire à les
renforcer
c'est ce gouvernement qui fait que
l'opération chez condra a été à la
hauteur et pour la première fois des
besoins en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration illégale sur le territoire
c'est ce gouvernement qui poursuit
résolument une politique de
développement structurel de mayotte
vous le savez c'est 1 27 milliard
d'euros qui sont là sur le plan d'avenir
il faut maintenant le mettre en oeuvre
vont à compléter sa mise en oeuvre c'est
ce gouvernement qui a renforcé de
manière significative les moyens en
matière de lutte contre la délinquance
et ça explique aussi peut-être certains
c'est un chiffre même s'il faut jamais
se satisfaire des résultats que l'on a
parce que le travail est encore long
pour qu'on atteigne nos objectifs à
mayotte
vous le savez je suis régulièrement à la
manoeuvre sur c'est sur ces sujets et je
je trouve toujours lamentable dont ces
périodes de crise qu'on se lasse aussi
aller pour certains la manipulation
populiste sa piste
c'est honteux parce qu'on a des
populations qui sont fragiles
qui souffrent et c'est extrêmement
facile de pouvoir les manipuler sur
mayotte sans classement en rouge vous
savez je l' ai dit dès les premiers
jours que je m'inquiétais fortement dans
cette période de kobe de 19 de la
situation de mayotte mayotte aujourd'hui
et le territoire où contrairement aux
autres territoires
le virus n'est pas encore maîtrisée
c'est pour ça que nous renforçons
régulièrement les moyens comme dans tous
les territoires on a doublé le nombre de
lits real enfin quand on parle de loin
on part de loin effectivement c'est tout
ça est aussi aussi discutable et
aujourd'hui nous avons un chiffre 2
excusez moi je cherche le chiffre de
nombreux de lui nous avons trois lits de
réanimation
non je crois que les petites erreurs
bienvenue dans l'animation souple et
merci de me donner un suppo caire parce
que j'ai pas sur les yeux mais on a
doublé le livre animations ont dépassé
de 17 me semble-t-il dans mes souvenirs
un chiffre qui est de 38 voilà de 16 à
38 g pas une si mauvaise mémoire que ça
de 16 à prendre syrie et puis vous le
savez ça a été demandé par les élus
je sais que notre le sénateur thani
entre autres à souhaitait effectivement
que les forces militaires se mobilisent
et puisse arriver renforcer ce nombre de
lits sur le territoire c'est pas un
hôpital de campagne je voulais déjà dit
la structure n'est pas là le nombre de
lits sera bien sûr augmenter et un
nombre de lits bien sûr c'est du
matériel des hommes dans le mois ce sera
10 et une centaine de plus de 80
personnes qui vont arriver et très vite
dès le début de la semaine prochaine un
premier module militaire de réanimation
qui arrivera par le premier avion il
faut deux à trois avions pour pouvoir
emmener l'ensemble des moyens sur sur
mayotte c'est bien sûr je veux remercier
l'accord entre mayotte et la réunion la
solidarité nationale la solidarité elle
aussi régional puisqu'il ya un accord
entre la réunion et mayotte pour les
évacuations sanitaires sur la question
du déconfinement à mayotte qui a
actuellement n'est pas terminée
désolé monsieur sénateur bailly une
réunion interministérielle sur ce sujet
du déconfinement ou du moins sur
l'adaptation à mayotte dans les
conditions actuelles du du confinement
sachant que soyons très honnête entre
nous le confinement à mayotte est sans
doute le territoire où il a le moins
marché je remercie tous ceux qui l'ont
respectée mais à côté de ça on a vu des
regroupements de 200 personnes des
jeunes des moins jeunes et je fais en
sorte de ne pas toujours à taizé que les
jeunes et là je compte sur effectivement
la classe politique pour rappeler que si
on veut effectivement que mayotte sorte
de cette période extrêmement difficile
il va falloir que les gestes barrières
soient appliquées va falloir que le port
du masque soit appliquée va falloir que
on accepte davantage le test quelque
chose qui n'est pas encore suffisamment
accepté à mayotte on mettra tous les
moyens pour aider mayotte
voilà dire quand même que j'ai une
petite pensée au moment où on parle mais
peut-être le sénateur en parlera pour la
guyane qui a aussi une problématique ou
du moins un cluster qui nous inquiète
fortement
voilà pour cette première série de
réponses je préfères tu étais trop
longue mais j'ai essayé de répondre à
tous et aussi beaucoup à la mini ce jeu
reconnaît en effet que vous avez balayé
point par point chacune des questions
qui voudraient opposer
or les collègues diront tout à l'heure
si les réponses sont satisfaisantes mais
en tout cas vous avez fait le travail
bien répondu à toutes les questions
je vais donc passer la parole j'ai trois
demandes d'intervention pour le moment
victoire jasse y avait je suis guidé
aide mais elle a cédé sa place il ya
victoire jasse maire dominique théophile
et catherine conconne dans l'horreur je
demanderai aux collègues est aussi
précis que possible dans la question et
vous avez la parole
on commence avec victoire
e victoire dont millwall n'est pas
ouvert désolé bonjour et merci beaucoup
mama ministre merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
bonjour à tous madame la ministre je
suis j'ai entendu vos premières réponses
consacré aux différents collègues qui
sont les rapporteurs et certaines
réponses me satisfait mais laxiste pour
vraiment mais j'ai d'autres questions
concernant d'une part un article 9 de la
de la dernière mesure prise par le
premier ministre concernant l'accès aux
plages et pour les personnes qui font de
la plaisance la plaisance justement ça
posera certainement pas de problème il y
à une association
tu m'as transmis du sage et je crois
qu'il faudrait qu'on soit vraiment au
clair par rapport à la situation
concernant le tourisme concernés
également toutes les personnes qui pâtit
que la plaisance il y a également
concernant le concernant l'aquarium de
la voix de lou l'encore il y à des
techniciens qui continue à travailler
ces termes il n'ya pas tous riches alors
que les revenus de cet aquarium
fonctionnement est liée au tourisme et
il y à des techniciens et aussi les
animaux qui sont à la fois pour la
recherche mais aussi pour la protection
et contribuent très fortement à
l'économie du pays
et là aussi il ya des mesures qui
seraient à prendre donc là c'est panique
je vous laisse le temps de réfléchir et
j'espère trouver ensemble des solutions
alors concernant l'agriculture vous l
avez évoqué effectivement celui-ci
autorise pas ce que vous avez à la fois
parler de privilégier les styles
clicquot ce qui est important
aujourd'hui parce que nous l'avons vu
grâce aux agriculteurs qui ont su
innover adaptateur quand ils disent
quand c'était possible leurs différentes
façons de rendre service je dirais à la
population avec l'aide de certaines
mères qui ont pu avoir la dérogation
pour les marchés mais on sait que avec
le tourisme on aura la possibilité
également de privilégier coup mais de
consommer les produits locaux lorsque
les agriculteurs ainsi que dans les
hôtels
c'est le nombre d'emplois directs et
indirects sont en jeu
aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que nous
devons maintenir toutes les actions
concernant la sécurité sanitaire
mais nous devons plus que jamais
trouvées et innover poursuivre
l'innovation et vous l'avez évoqué pour
permettre aux agriculteurs de s'en
sortir par un pêcheur de s'en sortir
mais surtout de maintenir les emplois
parce que là c'est un véritable risque
si toutefois on imagine n'était pas
prise et dans les délais donc il y a
aujourd'hui concernant l'accès aux
plages des dérogations qui sont
demandées demander qui peuvent être
demandée au préfet la mesure nous sommes
dans le vert et nous sommes entourés
d'eau je souhaiterais vraiment que des
mesures soient prises parce que
l'article 9 du décret du 11 mai concerne
l'interdiction des activités nautiques
et de plaisance alors que là si on
regarde bien il y a une activité
évidente sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires et de façon singulière de la
raddho
donc il faudrait peut-être que locution
voir comment faire pour que cette
activité redémarre si on veut vraiment
maintenir des différentes activités tout
en exigeant de toutes chacun que les
mesures spécifiques pour maintenir le
niveau de protection des populations et
des usagers soient respectés donc là et
puis vraiment je vous remercie j'ai
entendu certaines réponses déjà
concernant à la fois loin et le reste
donc je n'ai pas plus de questions pour
la mob anvers beaucoup la ministre et
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup chers collègues la parole donc
un communiqué au fil
oui bonjour bonjour madame la ministre
on ne la question de la fiscalité
messieurs vous savez le crédit d'impôt
investissement productif et moelleux
nous laissons aux ihu label règne c'est
le 31 décembre puis le hen pour la
chaire nord des délais s'ils sont réélus
et l'association actuelles laissent à
penser qu'un certain nombre
d'investissements aux lois à 16 e
édition des pros
soient réalisées ont élu la sphère
science frontières décembre 2000 faire
donc ma question est la suivante quelle
position est la bible de cernay jeudi
mais le stylet mais sinon c est elles
sont réelles mois la nouvelle échéance
et sur la question de loulou ne suis
tout à fait d'accord et oui d'ailleurs
mais c'est un sentiment marchés lui est
à pollenzo héros toutes ces situations
le problème sur les investisseurs mais
où on est 200 millions d'investissements
la voix de lou vous remettre en état les
autres moi je ne fais remarquer que les
efforts des locations pour 6 or on voit
les gouttes de sueur tout ce qui
concerne c'est ça le mieux
je crois qu'il faut qu'on sache qui est
visé est celui ci est vraiment forte de
son design et son admission sur les
factures nous refaire les
investissements gestion les élus
restaurant situation dans le cas échéant
solution on aura suivi pour cent si j'ai
vraiment excellent sony vient des
nationales
m
je suis j ou que je reste merci beaucoup
chers collègues la parole à catherine
conconne a pris si tu veux aller mais
dans métro c'est pas qui intervient par
apple oui bonjour
collègue jean président d'un jour madame
la ministre
les premiers mots sont comme j'encourage
et il vous dira que au milieu de cette
crise inédite
personne n'a jamais vécu ça c'est facile
de donner des leçons ici la sono médias
les réseaux sociaux sont communs
pourrait faire ils affrontent ce genre
de catastrophe pour laquelle on n'a
aucun recul je pense qu'il faut qu'on
fasse tous dans l'opinion et toute
preuve d'un peu d'humilité demandé qu'on
fasse plus c'est mais face à laigné 10
des mesures exceptionnelles et une
mobilisation exceptionnelle de votre
ministère et de vous-mêmes ont pu être
notées et en particulier aux côtés de
nos compatriotes étudiants qui ont pu
bénéficier d'une assistance de métier
leur est venue ce que vous faisiez vous
y est arrêté pour quelque chose et
également du rapatriement dans leur pays
d'origine
à partir de moyens qui sont
exceptionnellement débloquer alors
j'avais de prêts à vous soumettre juste
un premier je voulais vous rassurer la
situation de l'eau à la martinique
même si à ce moment nous sommes en
situation de pénurie n'est pas dû à des
problèmes d'infrastructures même s'il ya
quelques réparations à faire ici ou là
là particulier dans le fait qui a
bénéficié d'un réseau d'eau potable très
tôt que ne se créent dernier de l'est
milieu du siècle dernier
nous n'avons pas de problème ni de
ressources ou des distributions n'a
simplement mauvaise entente et une
mauvaise organisation de la distribution
sur place qui fait qu' il y ait deux
distributeurs de producteurs
saint-quentin et ce par la coupe on sait
et c'est là et population de rétention
des problèmes sur la distribution bon
nous sommes montés au créneau très
fortement nos artistes - récemment à
plusieurs reprises nous avons trouvé à
le côté un peu fait capi également chez
responsabilité qui le place anani
création et qui permet la main je vous
parle de dieu que l'appui pas de prêtre
est un peu nos vies comme ou chat
aujourd'hui à protéger ni que les choses
venues bats pour mes cuisses avait
prouvé une tente posée en nuances des
discussions que des faces structure ce
qui concerne la martinique même s'ils
avaient su 1 comme eux
comme partout de renouvellement de
réseau
fermez pas dans des proportions qui
pourraient justement occasionné cette
pénurie ambiante
ça c'est pour la famille en question la
deuxième question je voulais vous poser
a déjà été peu abordée c'est celle des
médias locaux et en particulier je pense
rôle a menti ni et la guadeloupe à atv a
essayé sur les deux yeux ce sont des
médias qui ont fait un boulot
extraordinaire pendant la pénurie qui
ont pas beaucoup de monde et s'est hissé
150 personnes sur les deux îles je me
rends valeur ajoutée sipa fait
répondants ont été extrêmement présente
aux côtés de la population pendant cette
crise du coc vie des moins des jeux on
relit un des messages en faisant venir
jusqu'à révéler sous comme une espèce de
thérapie collective calmer légion
pendant ces grosses difficultés que nous
avons connues et bien sûr ils ont pour
la plupart perdu 90 % de leurs recettes
publicitaires
c'est bien que les vingt sept de ces
médias la porte essentiellement sur la
publicité
ce assassin il était impossible aux
maîtres du monde en chômage partiel
impossible et donc il n'a pas la charge
sont restés identiques faire fonctionner
la nuit et jour sa demande des
journalistes de mountain view sa demande
des journalistes a demandé moynier de
moyens ont été constants met à
disposition de téléspectateurs et des
auditeurs mais avec des recettes en
chute alors bien sûr je les ai
auditionné hier qu'il s'agisse des
médias d'un million de la guadeloupe
guadeloupe martinique s'automatise mixte
juillet celui des îles et puis à tvg des
chiffres je m'apprête à saisir le
premier ministre gué sûr vous serez mais
sa copie dans la journée et si que bruno
le maire pour kaboul moyens
exceptionnels le domaine comme je cumule
tue tout il vraiment pas autrement ça ça
va vraiment pas chercher très loin très
nombreux mais lors de ce flot de besoins
auxquels le gouvernement doit faire face
aujourd'hui est un petit produit un cri
qui dit et je vais vous le traduire en
jouant tête à tête
sinon j'aime bien fait pas un papy c'est
donc le aujourd'hui ces besoins sont ce
qu'ils sont ne passez pas le style et le
dos 3 mios d'horreur boston john tôt
pour éviter des catastrophes
on vous a vu au combat concerne pas
senti
aujourd'hui son sentiment
malheureusement convient de bien on n'a
pas pu pousser sa chose investissement
et son retour sur la scène médiatique
aussi fortement qu'il l'aurait souhaité
mais font senti et de le tourner mon
attention le nez nous permet d'être
informé également courriel et vous savez
en tout cas cette époque pousser les
moyens pour que ceux ci puissent
bénéficier de fonds exceptionnel
d'investissement et assurer ainsi
assurer ainsi vous l'avais dit dans
votre introduction une pluralité des
médias dont on a besoin
nos territoires sont petits les marchés
sont pas très il ne peut pas se
contenter de la voie que les services
publics de l'information aux côtés de
nos populations
je compte sur vous pousse la troisième
transaction concerne et la fiscalité des
collectivités d'outre-mer vous savez que
ces devises a mis en cause qui se
recouvrent les budgets les moyens
budgétaires des collectivités mairies
collectivités
cela consiste à l'it et locales en
particulier l'autre mais en particulier
la taxe passagers en particulier la taxe
sur les carburants
et vous imaginez bien pas besoin de vous
faire un dessin que tout cela est à la
baisse
vraiment à la baisse les produits à
faible valeur ajoutée localement par
exemple ne sont pas ceux qui ont été le
plus consommé ya pas eu de fait on a
attaqué dans le col on ne sait pas ce
tableau n'a pas acheté deux voitures en
ses rêves
ce qui fait que les collectivités
locales vont connaître une baisse
drastique de leurs recettes d'octroi de
mer
j'ai donc et j'avais donc on fait un
amendement dans le plfr à ce sujet
belmont taux suggéré qu'ils soient
recomptés je ne vais pas leur alliance
mais en tout cas il faudrait absolument
assurer à son collectivité n'a pas une
stabilité trésorerie puisqu'elles
mécanisme qui fait que chaque mois iata
temps policiers blessés ou collectivités
que le coin et sans cette année nous
lorsque le premier va se faire au moins
un manque à gagner important certaines
collectivités mais en fait déjà remonté
documents qui pourraient se chiffrer à
2,7 à -70%
en ce qui concerne collectivités locales
et bien sûr la collectivité majeur la
collectivité territoriale de montigny
qui ont qui reçoit quand même 65
millions
on dort chaque année en recettes seller
kaboul ans et presque deux millions
d'euros sur la taxe passager est en plus
de trafic passagers plus de détaxe au
sixième rang dans la doc de trois
éléments auxquels je vais pas à vous et
merci encore de votre implication vous
serez pas plus que jamais bon courage
merci beaucoup cher que l'oeil manono
mini je vais vous proposer peut-être de
répondre à ces trois questions
puis j'ai deux autres demandes pour le
moment guillaume arnel et antoine karam
donc si vous voulez répondre à ces trois
intervenants et nous passerons aux
autres questions
j'avais la parole monsieur le président
vous aime la sénatrice l'histoire heures
et jasmin vous m'avez interrogée sur
l'article 7 du 12 mai et sur la question
effectivement de des activités liées à
l'accès à la plage à la présence ou à
d'autres bassins où on peut pratiquer à
ce manque d'activité
ce qu'il faut retenir de cet article 7
c'est le principe d'interdiction avec la
possibilité pour les préfets dans chaque
territoire de pouvoir autoriser ou
adapter la connaît on est sur exactement
la même chose que pour les marchés les
marchés étaient interdits et quand un
maire souhaitait effectivement ouvrir
son marché
il sollicitait le préfet on sent qu'il
regardait les conditions à quai les
choses pouvaient se faire et il y avait
une autorisation préfectorale
et alors on a fait la même chose c'est à
dire que y'a principe d'interdiction
mais si tu as un dossier monté par amer
instruit par la préfecture abouti à des
autorisations nous pouvons nous pouvons
le faire sur les sujets accès accès aux
plages comme à la présence aux
différentes activités j'ai bien compris
cette volonté de
réouvrir un certain nombre de d'activité
c'est très bien qu'on puisse les avoir
organisées de cette sorte à dire moi je
suis pour qu'on laisse la possibilité à
chaque effet d'adapter sur les
territoires il ya deux cadres et puis à
l'adaptation dans chaque territoire
puisque de toute façon en plus vous
savez même s'il ya le vert et le rouge
dans le vert il ya chez nous chez nous
tous les territoires
ils n'ont pas du tout les mêmes les
mêmes conditions épidémiologique
d'ailleurs le rapport qui a été rendu
hier soir par le conseil scientifique
fait bien trois groupes et c'est
intéressant à noter il ya effectivement
le premier groupe qui concerne mayotte
pour qui des décisions effectivement
aujourd'hui sans lui au fait tu es fois
où le virus fortement je rappelle que le
nombre de cas à mayotte c'est la moitié
de nos cas outre-mer est le deuxième
groupe on va dire que c'est celui qui a
vu le virus régresser où on peut dire
pour maîtrise les choses et puis il ya
le troisième route où il ya soit pas le
cas
soit très peu de taches ou put pas du
tout et c'est comme ça que sont classés
effectivement les trois des trois
groupes de territoires ultramarins et
donc ça montre bien qu'à l'intérieur de
ça il faudra de ces différents groupes
vont permettre au préfet de pouvoir
adapter en lien avec les élus en charge
des différents des différents sujets sur
monsieur le sénateur théophile la
question la question de l'eau en
guadeloupe alors vous savez la question
de l'eau en guadeloupe moi depuis que je
suis ici ça fait donc plus de trois ans
maintenant si peu plus de trois ans
maintenant et bien sur ce sujet nous
avons travaillé les visites de sébastien
lecornu à l'époque au mts les miennes
nous sommes revenus d'ailleurs quand il
était chargé des collectivités manuel
wargon notamment également dernièrement
le président de la république lors de
son déplacement en guadeloupe
nous avons tous abordé la question de
l'eau c'était travaux notamment pour la
guadeloupe comme d'ailleurs pour tous
les territoires amara qui se font dans
le cadre du plan ou d'hommes qui a été
réactivé pour lequel l'état a mis un
certain nombre de crédits pour
accompagner les collectivités
le préfet vous savez accompagne les
différentes collectivités dernièrement
il a fait un certain nombre de
réquisition nous allons débloquer très
rapidement cinq réunions d'euros pour
que des travaux d'urgence se coiffer au
delà des investissements dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure c'était de 79
millions d'euros pour lequel ans devait
on doit réaliser les travaux afin avant
la fin de l'année 2020 rappelle le
président avec dès lors de son passage
dans 18 mois il ne faut plus qu'il y ait
deux tours d'eau pour dos et des
coupures d'eau à chacun son tour sur un
territoire compte en banque
effectivement d'eau ou de là
effectivement des travaux d'urgence et
bien il ya une planification sans donner
de date je peux vous dire que lors de ma
prochaine visite avec emmanuelle wargon
et bien le sujet où sera au coeur dans
les antilles bon je regardais quand
est-ce qu'on peut venir sur le
territoire
parce que c'est un sujet extrêmement
important et les guadeloupéens nous
attendent sur ce sur ce sujet mais sur
le sujet de la gouvernance notamment
vous savez très bien monsieur le
sénateur pourrait y avoir travaillé je
vous en remercie avec le gouvernement et
avec les collectivités de votre
territoire
on arrive à effectivement avoir cette
structure unique de gestion
ce qu'on n'a pas réussi à faire
aujourd'hui avec sans doute beaucoup de
bonnes attentions sur le territoire et
compris la nôtre mais pas suffisamment
pour pouvoir y arriver là c'est une
mission que j'ai effectivement confié ou
au préfet gustin et qui l'amène sur sur
le territoire en concertation avec avec
chacun sur la question de la
prolongation
crédit d'impôt pour investissements
productifs en outre-mer et bien je
voudrais vous dire que ce crédit d'impôt
244 quater w parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on le dit a déjà été étendue jusqu'en
2025 sur des biens immobiliers et la
réhabilitation hôtelière et pour les
autres bien y'a pas n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de limite
donc ces pièces est posé on en est là à
l'orée d'une autorisation des aides
d'état s'arrête et 31 12
nous avons effectivement là à leur
notifier le plus rapidement possible de
manière à ce qu'on continue
effectivement on a travaillé ensemble le
ministère a mandaté un cabinet pour
adresser un rapport à la commission le
plus vite le plus vite possible et
sénatrice catherine conconne vous m'avez
interrogé par vous avez parlé de la
situation des médias pour vous avez
effectivement une occasion de
d'auditionner moi c'est entièrement
d'accord avec vous voulez dit tout à
l'heure dans les moments de crise en
sont bien combien on a besoin de nos
médias et vous avez raison de dire que
ces médias aurait plus de travail que
jamais au moment où une plus grosse est
d'abord liée aux publicités c'est la
seule recette on vous voit là pour aux
recettes qui est et qui alimente
effectivement nos médias en disent ont
été sur le franc eux aussi s'étaient
souvent en deuxième ligne voir à côté de
ceux qui étaient en première ligne
ils n'ont pas pu bénéficier du chômage
partiel effectivement tout en équipe
était sur le terrain en même temps les
ans a pu non plus du coup baisser leurs
charges et donc ce sont des activités
qui auront beaucoup souffert de cette
crise et pour lequel je l'espère c'est
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure avec le
ministre de la culture nous pouvons
faire des annonces sous peu après des
arbitrages interministériels devant
avoir lieu où vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice dans ces moments il faut qu'on
soit tous abl d'abord parce que je les
ai dit tout à l'heure les vérités ont
une durée de vie très limitée que les
choses avancent qu'on apprend
non parce que ce virus il a touché le
monde entier nous a bouleversés à la
fois nos structures sanitaires mais
notre économie notre équilibre social
dans les dans les différents territoires
et oui il faut effectivement qu'on
n'apprenne chacun à respecter
l'hésitation hésitation ou quelquefois
ce que jugée comme de la lenteur comme
une capacité à réfléchir malgré tout
l'adaptation avec tout ce qu'elle peut
fois ça prend un peu plus de temps parce
qu'on fait de la concertation pour les
collectivités parce que vous avez
effectivement vous aussi rappelé les
difficultés d'abord vous dire qu'avec la
ministre
jacqueline gourault nous en parlant
régulièrement c'est plus c'est vous le
savez sébastien lecornu qui travaillent
sur ce dossier et il connaît bien les
territoires à marare un peu lui aussi il
est venu dans beaucoup de dents beaucoup
de territoires et sur plusieurs sujets
et dont ces deux portefeuilles la crise
elle devrait effectivement fortement
impacté les projets dont on a besoin
d'eux objectiver les données que l'on à
aujourd'hui qui nous sont remontés par
les requérants parlementaires bien sûr
par les régions et les départements les
communes elles-mêmes
il faut qu'on puisse savoir exactement
mesurer les choses j'aurais envie de
dire que on le traite peut-être un peu
moins dans l'urgence que les autres les
idées autre sujet c'est le sujet qui
arrive maintenant c'est toutes les
autres mesures d'accompagnement que son
ami sans doute parce que je voulais dit
tout à l'heure les communes reste
accompagnée par les régions par les
départements selon les soutiens mais on
sait pertinemment effectifs compétition
de croisière de la taxe sur les
carburants la consommation dans les
territoires vont produire les effets
assez rapidement et vous voulez nous les
aidons instruction a été donnée
effectivement à chaque effet de faire
aussi le point se préparer à cette
mission cazenave et à former davantage
effectivement le député gaza sur ce
sujet on a été tout à l'heure les
possibilités de faire des avances sur la
fiscalité des cas les demandes nous
pouvons aller satisfaire sous les
demandes
il faut objectiver et ans
on peut le faire pour l'éditeur cette
mesure elle est prise puis il faut
effectivement que l'on puisse travailler
ensemble sur les différentes solutions
sans oublier le rapport passion qui lui
aussi faisait un certain nombre de
propositions qu'il nous faut pas oublier
parce qu'elle était dans la durée elle
n'était pas dans une période de crise
vers l'est sont tout aussi importantes
et intéressantes pour les téléphones
c'était l'audition de la ministre d
outre-mer annick girardin devant les
sénateurs
la ministre s'est attardé sur la
situation à mayotte l'île étant placée
en zone rouge
et elle la sueur pour que le
déconfinement soit possible sur l'île de
mayotte
il faut que la population accepte
davantage le port du masque et la
pratique de tests
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi rester informé
sur cette crise sanitaire sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
[Musique]